Yeah, it's the Mama Max, Nuxtaku, and now this situation all
exhibit the same pattern of behavior for Mudahar, right? It is
the same pattern of behavior. Minimizing what he did wrong, refusing
to acknowledge stuff. Oh, I'm going to actually walk away for
a while, guys. I'm going to actually walk away. I'm going to
go over here. I'm going to pretend I don't know about any of
this for a little bit, right? >> A worthless, spineless
pushover. Somehow, his actions in this situation were even more
pathetic than pretending to be different kinds of engineer for
a >> If you want to stick around, awesome. If you still
feel wronged and this does not suffice for you, then um I don't
really give a simple as that. >> At the time this video
was made, the OP of this post was a 12year-old child. They were
me. That's that is brutal.
We'll start with the Mudahar stuff. We'll go right now on the
Mudahar stuff because I can start with uh this harmful opinions
video right now. Now, I believe we we might have watched this
on stream. There's a timeline here where Mudahar apologized.
So, uh how should we do this? Harmful opinions put out this video.
Then he put out a video kind of exposing Mudahar and Nexo. Big
massive YouTuber Nexo. Okay, you guys remember Nexo? I believe
Nexo is the guy, if I'm not mistaken, who did the JFK video,
right? Is that No, it's not that guy. This guy does horror videos.
Sorry, sorry, sorry. I'm I'm thinking of um who did the JFK video
that was really good. It's not this guy. The one with the exe.
I'm thinking of somebody else. Anyway, this this Nexo guy and
Mudahar had made out while drunk. Armful opinions went pretty
hard on it and then had to retract some of that stuff. Okay.
Yeah, it looks like he's basically just Wendigon essentially.
Wendigon.
Nothing else. Okay. So, that happened and then Harmful had to
retract some of that story and all that's left is his retraction
video now. I'm thinking of Let me know. Yeah, I'm thinking to
let me know. Did Nexo do the videos about the guys who died in
the mountains? Um, he probably did a video on them cuz he looks
to do like conspiracy horror stuff, but >> Oh, give me
one. [__] >> I just I started the stream a
little too quickly, I think, to see. Oh, these headphones are
fine. I thought my my regular headphones weren't working, but
they are. I'll connect them. Gotcha. All right, we're into the
right headphones here based. All right, dude. I just I went I
was way too goofy about this. So anyway, harmful opinions releases
he releases this video. Then he does the other the next one which
is the gay one. Then he releases his apology. Mudahar between
the gay one and the apology releases his own video. Um just a
regular video and he takes about 30 seconds to address his drama
and sort of says it. Oh, Portoella, if you want to, that would
be really appreciated. Thank you very much. Um
God, somebody also sent me the Mudahar retraction.
We'll have to go back and find that as well tonight. Okay, hold
on. So, looking around, there's some Vtuber abuse stuff as well.
Okay, we got Mudahar's scandal. And then we've got this guy.
Okay, so anyway, I'm going to run through all of it cuz I didn't
watch the military video yet. So, I'm going to watch this. I'm
going to go get my water, my drink really quickly cuz I've also
not done that yet. All right, guys. And I'm going to I'm going
to going to reflect on how I started this stream about 10 minutes
too early because I had some some more to do. But now we got
social stream working again. It's like all perfectly working.
It's not broken anymore, which is very nice. So, we're also back
at like an earlier time slot. Mercurina threw hands. They appear
to have thrown hands. Yes, I believe that is the case. Okay,
let me uh let me hit play on this and we'll go. All right. Oh,
I need to switch the music up as well. Okay, we're starting with
Mudahar updates. We've not been following the Mudahar close mutasar
the Mudahar stuff as closely as some other people, but we're
going to clean it all up cuz now I don't know if there's anything
else that's going to happen. Like at this point, we've got the
Mudar stuff out and
and I think he probably doesn't really have to address it anymore.
They appear. It appears based on all Did I say Mudasar?
I did not do that. That is not real. Mutasar. Mutasar. Oh, also,
yeah, guys, engage with the blastoff tweet. We got a blastoff
tweet over here. Perfectly good blastoff tweet. Okay, we are
horde. We are Mongols. We are one. We are a horde. Okay, engage
with the blastoff tweet. I believe it is pinned in both chats.
Yes. Oh Jesus, that's cool. I believe it's pinned in both chats.
Engage with the blastoff tweet. Like the blastoff tweet. And
let's go to the moodar video. Start the stream. I'm grabbing
my drinks. I will be right back. Right back in 2 >> That's
the face that says I should have picked engineering in college.
>> For those of you unaware of current drama, it turns
out Mutahar of some ordinary gamers is a man who likes to tell
stories about himself. Now, that in itself isn't a problem. I
personally love to share stories about what I've been up to,
but he has this habit of talking about the same thing multiple
times in ways that give very different impressions. Just as a
quick example before we get into today's topic, one of the main
ones people have picked up on is how he talks about his education.
In a 2019 stream, he was asked about his academic background.
>> Education background asking a lot asking because a lot
of CS knowledge. Uh yeah, I did computer engineering when I went
to college. That's what I did. And then I switched my career
to post-production film editing because it was just far more
interesting and lucrative. I guess that adds. Anyways though,
I'm going to end the stream for this. >> I would suggest
that if you're asked about your educational background and you
say you went to college for computer engineering, you are telling
that person you got a qualification. In this case, because it
was a live stream, he was telling the world that. But of course,
elsewhere you can find him saying he never got his degree. Ah,
>> you should you should totally ignore college. I don't
use my degree and I haven't used it for like six years. >> I
didn't even get my degree, dude. That's the best part.
So, this is all interesting, right? There there's like a an actual
debate here of like, oh, if he's very clear in some places, right?
You I will just be your pay. >> Oh, hello. >> Reban
Ruben donated $3. Is this a VTuber or a screen saver? >> What
do you mean VTuber screen saver? Do you mean
what? Also, yeah. Did chat just die? Yeah. Oh, weird. Oh, I thought
my browser I thought my browser chat was fixed, but it is not.
Okay, so he doesn't make it clear
and a lot of people will say, "Oh, it's not a problem, right?
Is that a Oh, volume's too low. Okay, we turned around." A lot
of people will say that like, "Oh, well, he he said over here
that he's not an engineer, right? It's about where do you where
do you draw lines and where do you figure out like how clear
you have to be?" I would say with an engineering qualification,
if you're representing yourself as an engineer in Canada, you
probably have to be really clear all the time. You probably can't
like barely step over some lines, that's probably not good. It's
a protected qualification. You should be very specific, very
exacting in how you describe it. Um, I don't think he faced any
legal penalties for what's been shown here, but I think harmful
harmful shows he talks about computer engineering. He is kind
of saying he has the qualification. I would agree on that. I
would not say he's like representing his services as such, right?
Why does it matter so much in Canada? Because it is a professional
college like a professional
uh there's like a professional engineering organization that
actually has powers vested in it through the through the provincial
governments to like penalize people who represent themselves
as engineers without having the title. So it's like a it's a
big thing here like you it'd be like saying you have a doctor
or you have an MD, right? It's sort of equivalent. So he should
have been more careful.
I would say the issue here is he leaves it muddy and then he
says I'm an engineer. I'm an engineer. I'm an engineer. As an
engineer as an engineer as an engineer. So if you if you leave
it muddy like that. If you say you did computer engineering in
college and that doesn't apply to software engineers only if
that's your title given to you explicitly by your job. Demiurge.
Um I do believe there are some engineering colleges that actually
offer specifically software engineering.
So like if that is your title, I don't think they'll penalize
you for having that as your title at your job because there are
US companies who might give you that title or something. But
in general, they don't like like that is a big fight in Canada
about like software engineering basically using that as a term.
So anyway, when he leaves it muddy and when he claims to have
that qualification, but then he says, "I'm an engineer. I'm an
engineer. I'm an engineer. I have like a lot of background in
engineering. I've done stuff. I've done a bunch of tech stuff.
I used to do pen testing. I used to do all the security stuff."
Right? when he when you add all of these things in that starts
to you're leaning on the qualification, you're leaning on that
muddiness. So, I think it starts to get a lot less muddy or a
lot less confusing when you look at the totality of Mudahar representing
himself. If you just look at like one or two clips, it it's really
easy to say, "Well, he actually said he didn't like he he actually
said he dropped out, but did like you said you dropped out in
one video out of a million videos, three videos out of a million
videos, maybe a 100 videos out of a million videos, and then
in in like a couple hundred thousand of those videos, you say,
"I'm an engineer." It's like the broad body is going to vastly
outstrip the broad body of engineer claims are going to vastly
outstrip you clarifying. What was he saying he was qualified
for? Or am I dumb? So, he said, "Uh, I did computer engineering
on a stream, right?" And Harmful is making the argument that
he's claiming he has a computer engineering degree there. I don't
know if it's quite that strong, but like that's why I'm saying
I don't know if it's quite that strong in a vacuum, but what
in totality it's definitely like strong. It's way stronger, I
would argue. Okay, let's >> Not college. >> I remember
I remember the best part about high school was my 12th grade
English teacher said that I would amount to a failure. He's a
guy who said what seems to be the truth in some places if apparently
inebriated enough, but is happy to paint a different picture
when he's more on the ball. Oh, but technically he did go to
college for it for one semester. All right, try pulling that
with the people in your life and enjoy your reputation as a weird
lying freak. And another area of his life he seems to have done
this in, but I haven't seen anyone picking up on is his past
interest in the military. In 2023, Mutahar was asked about his
ability to speak French, and he said this. I can speak it like
if you if you put a gun to my head. Actually, no. I know enough
like my wire get by speaking French cuz there was a period of
my life where I was joining the uh Royal Air. >> Oh, I
should just say as far as the reputation is a weird line for
Yeah, you shouldn't misrepresent yourself. I think it's always
best. Oh, are you guys getting duplicate messages? Oh, it's duplicating.
Hold on. Oh, I see. I see. I can't have that like that. I Okay,
fair enough. Fair enough. Okay, it's fixed. It's fixed, guys.
It's fixed. So, I I've always lean and I don't know if other
people do this. I always underqualify my job, right? I always
I always say like I don't really know. I try to underell as much
as possible. I don't understand people who oversell like that
in like social situations. I find people who are like quite confident
in their qualifications, in their careers, they do underell.
Like, it's just it's way better to underell. Jeez, the duplicate
messages. That was [__] up. All right. My tech literate
streamer. It has nothing to do with tech literacy. It has to
do with this. So, the social stream tab constantly dies for some
reason in my browser. I have no idea why. No clue why it just
dies randomly, but it does. Maybe I should open it in another
tab or like in Firefox or Edge or something. Maybe that would
be better so I'm not over by it. You know, you know, you know.
Anyway, yeah, if you're if you're confident, you underell. You
oversell when you don't know. Some people who oversell could
be highly qualified and are just super arrogant about it. I don't.
That's possible, but it's just not the broad base of it, right?
It's not like by and far people who oversell, I mean, technically
that's not true because overselling implies that you are, you
know, that you're not qualified or as qualified as you represent
yourself, but most people who oversell hard are not as competent.
I found >> force here like the Canadian >> my experience
in life >> and if you join a government-like military position,
you have to know both languages kind of. So, >> turns out
that Mutahar, the engineer and globe trottting film producer
was also joining the Royal Air Force. >> Military was like
it was like this was like way back in the day. Like this was
like before high school. Um, and >> what he does clarify
>> this never happened. >> Fair enough. I'll believe
him on that. >> But like the only reason I looked at the
Air Force is like I couldn't afford I >> this happened
in high school but it didn't happen. >> Couldn't afford
university and I wasn't going to go through a loan. So I was
>> oh, when he said he was joining the Royal Air Force,
he meant he was fantasizing about doing that as a way to pay
for a degree. Cuz at the time, before high school, he couldn't
afford university and didn't want to take a loan. But didn't
happen. Never tried to do that. Whatever. It was just a pre high
school fantasy. That on its own, I guess, is whatever. But there's
something a bit weird here going on. A couple years earlier,
talking to Dr. K of Healthy Gamer GG, he told a similar story.
This time, though, it wasn't the Royal Canadian F. >> Hello.
Reuben Ruben donated $3. Look, look at his avatar head just floating
around like a screen saver. >> Hey, can you chill, bro?
Can you chill? Can you chill, Reuben? Reuben, what are you doing?
What are you doing to me here? What are you trying to do? What
are you trying to do here? >> The army. He says it was
after high school. And he says he did actually >> After
high school, it was just I I actually applied to the army, but
you know, that didn't go anywhere. Eventually, I just worked.
I went to university for computer sciences and that's it. To
be clear in this interview, he does clarify that he was a >> When
I I thought when I got into university for a while and I dropped
out like a semester in because I was like, "Okay, no, no. I'm
not doing cuz University of Toronto, like the first semester
that you went in, you paid this crazy amount." >> There's
a slightly questionable thing here as well, though. He explains
to Dr. K that the reason he dropped out was that school's very,
very expensive. And at the same time, he was getting >> I
He's a Canadian citizen, right? Mudahar. He's definitely a Canadian
citizen, right? he'd be a resident of Ontario. Shouldn't this
school in Ontario be not that expensive for him? I feel like
I know U of is expensive or like it's a good school, but I would
imagine for like in province people who qualify to go that it
it really shouldn't be, right? It shouldn't be that expensive.
>> More work on the side. So, you had to choose does he
pursue that or does he pursue school? And >> uh at this
point, I started, you know, getting more work on the side. I
started building up a career. First, I was like, "Wait a minute.
Do I choose to go through this university path which will work
for me or to go out on the career path?" That's when I realized
like, "Okay, I'm on that tight road." >> But at the time,
his explanation was significantly different. He would frequently
thank his YouTube viewers for enabling him to get off the path
he was on, one he found depressing, not because he was making
the calculation he was presenting to Dr. K. But >> yeah,
like it's really not that expensive. If you are in Canada, your
parents are a
like if your parents are a that's 9 to 10k per ye per semester,
right? Like that's not that's not that bad. That's really not
that bad because it simply wasn't what he wanted to do. >> What
else did I have forward to look to in my life? Future of a menial
job and whatnot. You know, just becoming the standard 9 toive
guy. No, at this point, you guys have made me change my entire
career path. I am on my way to become what I want to be, a documentary
filmmaker. All right. I'm on my way to become one of those. All
right. >> And he didn't simply leave education to pursue
a career. He wasn't simply dropping education for work. He still
needed a different education. He went to film school instead,
which was his passion. I don't know. I think if I was talking
to someone about this, I would have brought that up. A minor
point, sure, but why did none of his stories ever stay the same?
On that topic, Dr. K asked him what work he was doing in high
school. And so you said you were >> That's I
how do I put this? Harmful opinions will quibble on like very
very very small points in my opinion. Like make them a little
too important when like they seem not that important to me. But
I I understand it's like just a little autism. It's uh it's not
too bad. Anyway, that's what I think that was. He just he doesn't
like when there's like realistically if you get asked why you
dropped out of school, it should be the same answer every time,
right? It shouldn't change. >> In high school, what kind
of work did you do in high school? uh just computer work early
and that's what I was doing you know your basic like part-time
work nothing you know substantial I was also a student at the
time and uh in fact a lot of my work really ended up being just
like basic community service work just to rack on the hours >> that
all sounds fine doesn't it but he's told that story before >> I
was basically finishing up my you know high school diploma and
everything and at the time you know I worked a little computer
programming job I I worked as a pen tester you You know what
I mean? Like I got into the whole thing early. I had a couple
connections. That's it's a pretty it's a pretty important job
and I was good at it. I made a fair amount of money at it. And
you know if >> So if you remember from earlier videos,
he doesn't seem to have any experience being a pentester at all.
>> If I still did that job, [__] I'd be, you
know, a lot more richer than I would be, you know, at any point
in time. But bottom line is I used to work a job like that out.
And that was one of >> or maybe he did. Maybe that's different
than the other tech job he had. But there were so few years to
actually combine the two. It just seems odd years that I had.
>> I guess now that's just become a little part-time job
and he mostly did community work. Back in the day though, he
was using that experience to make claims like this to hundreds
of thousands of people. Guys, I'm a computer like I'm a I'm a
cyber security expert. I've worked in the business. I I know
what I'm doing. All right? And this is why I always give a disclaimer.
Be careful. All right. Let the >> ah see this is this is
the issue is he's built like a whole body of work where he has
represented himself this way. I think he's gone and like taken
down a ton of his old videos and VODs as well. >> Yeah,
I'm pretty sure >> handle it. I'm a professional. I got
>> A lot of people aren't bothered. They don't think it's
weird. He was just a baby. He was merely a freshly 21-year-old
toddler. He's surely grown out of it. Me, I think it's weird
as And back to the topic of this video after that tangent. There's
another thing I find weird as. Apparently 5 years ago, someone
recorded one of his streams and re-uploaded it. The stuff you'll
see on the desktop is whatever that guy was doing. In this broadcast,
he talks about his plan to go into the military. But he starts
the story in a way I find very very strange. >> Give Let
me just give you this let me just give you this scenario, okay?
Like real quick. This is this is sort of my if if I wasn't engineering.
>> If he was in engineering, what the hell does that mean?
Oh, maybe he was saying if I wasn't in engineering, I'd go into
the military. No, this is about how he was going to get his engineering
degree. >> One of the things that I was actually doing
one day was like, >> "Wait, what does this mean?" It was
a little weird. He to Martin Shellyley if he was confident in
what he was saying. Did he go toe-to-toe with Shreley on something?
Where did that happen, Rhox? I've never heard of that one. >> Before
before college or anything, I actually thought about, you know,
going into the military and [__] And when you go
into the military, I was planning on going to the military to
like study >> but that didn't work out. He said to Dr.
K. He said he didn't want to take a loan. So instead, was he
just going to pay out of pocket for an engineering degree with
his side gigs? What is happening here? I'm happy to be shown
I'm just misunderstanding things and I'm lacking information.
In fact, I'd love to hear the story because it sounds like it
must be incredible. You can say he has a right to keep things
private, but that's not quite right. He did, but he chose not
to. He chose to blab endlessly about his life actually to an
audience. Well, also I would say you have a right to privacy
until you create like a valid public interest to to like for
people to dig, right? I would say at this point there's probably
a valid public interest to dig on the engineer claims,
right? That that didn't exist before. At this point, I would
say 100% there's a valid public interest. Like you are one of
the biggest YouTubers. You are a massive YouTuber. Not one of
the biggest, but you are a massive YouTuber. You're one of the
biggest in the tech space, like in the especially in like the
tech hobbyist space. and you've represented yourself really poorly
and now it sounds like in a old stream you might not have even
gone to engineering school at all. Did you even get in? Did you
even What >> Audience of thousands upon thousands of people.
People aren't climbing in his damn walls. They're asking about
public media. He p >> Yeah, I think the kick notifications
didn't go out skirt him unfortunately. I threw an at here in
the what do you call it in the
in the Discord. But yeah, if you're not in the Discord, you would
have missed it. lished and Mutahar himself has warned against
trusting people who claim expertise on the internet. >> Uh
Assassin's Creed Shadows, a game that has so much controversy
right now. Tons of grifty accounts online, fell for this one
[__] person lying about their, you know, credentials
as a Japanese uh university historian expert even though it took
5 seconds to way back machine their account. And >> yep,
good tip. Thanks, Mutah. I used it. Other tools as well are very
useful for checking these things. figure out, oh, they were just
some random white guy from uh, you know, some part in Indiana,
okay? Some random dude on the internet. And even if you took
their Japanese like name, put it into like the Tokyo University
or whatever university they claim to be, you couldn't even find
that >> Another good tip, there's a tool that works just
like that for engineers in your province. You plug someone's
name in to see if they're licensed. >> See, people don't
even want to do the bare minimum of research. Nobody wants to
do even 5 minutes of research, >> but they'll believe anything
an account
true. Thank you, M. By the way, I've seen some people, >> Dude,
how did this guy put his foot in his mouth so regularly for like
years?
It's so It's like crazy how much he puts his foot in his mouth
all the time. >> Hello, guys. >> How How to say he
never claimed to be working as an engineer. Personally, I get
a different impression from statements like this from 2023. As
an engineer, if I show up to my office
and I up,
okay, I don't have a job anymore. >> I'm sure the guy who
calls himself an engineer every 2 seconds and tells everyone
YouTube isn't his job, he has a real one, was purely talking
hypothetically. Let's hop back to that other clip. And he explains
why even if someone making such claims hasn't done something
wrong yet, there's always a future threat if they're accepted
as an authority and no one checks. Now imagine with generative
AI taking the extra >> Dude, it's also I think he went
super hard on Pirate Software for this too, like misrepresenting
his qualifications >> for steps to, you know, bulletproof
this account and make it look even more legitimate. You could
actually go beyond just goofing on Assassin's Creed Shadows and
turn it into serious misinformation. Imagine an actual piece
of misinformation suddenly showing up on national news, international
news, spreading like wildfire. And it was not until the actual
bomb blows that people start correcting themselves. That's a
serious issue and that's something that I think people need to
watch out for going forward. >> Damn straight. You got
to catch things early, check them and get them straightened out
cuz you know people have asked >> agree with this entirely
Jay Pineone. That's exactly how it is. >> What has he said
that's wrong? And I have no idea. That's the problem. As a layman
listening to him, if he said something wrong, I would believe
it's >> Well, just uh just check it for yourself. What?
just nip out, get an education real quick so I can be sure that
I understand what I'm looking at. Nah, deceptive claims of expertise
or credentials or experience are a problem in and of themselves.
And you just heard Mutahar lay out a much stronger case for that
than I will. And I'm sure any day now he'll clear all this up
and I'll cover that as well. Uh, well, he kind of does. Oh, there's
the new Nandros video. Okay, we've got we've got the new NARS
video here. There's a lot of this stuff. Okay, hold on. Let me
go let me go back to my docket. So, okay.
Now, there is a missing harmful Oh, no. There's not a missing
harmful opinions video. I do want to watch it cuz it's just good
for context. Hold on, let me pull it up. So, there's another
harmful opinions video that came out. It's this one right here.
>> Many people would say that >> Mudahar Mudahar's
gay cheating scandal update/corrections
in description. So, I'll read the updates and corrections before
we go just so people have them in mind so we don't like uh totally
over Mudahar on this one, you know. Updates, corrections. I found
older mentions of a possible Ryan that is seemingly not an expo.
While it previously seemed apparent that this was the Ryan being
referred to, it is likely the other Ryan instead. Oh, it is likely
this is this other Ryan instead. Upon further checking, the 2019
wedding is not Kyle's, which in fact occurred in 2017. This means
the ill girlfriend does not line up with the gay cheating story.
Oh, actually,
maybe this this stuff this might not be a good video. that this
that's like the entire premise of the video is Harmful thought
he found out that one Mudahar was gay cheating on a girlfriend.
Okay, he thought that and two he also sorry Harmful also thought
that Mudahar had he talked to Dr. K about breaking up with a
girlfriend who had a terminal illness and it seemed like the
the timeline lined up so that it was basically possibly the gay
cheating that caused him to break up with the um with the girlfriend
with the terminal illness. But it seems like the entire video
is actually no longer correct, which is too bad. I'll I'll watch
correction video really quickly. >> because it's important
to look at >> Donated $3. If Mudahar and food shops had
a baby, it name would be Fut, you know. Never mind.
>> Okay. Thank you so much, Reuben Ruben. I appreciate
you, buddy. Thank you so much for the three. Good stuff. Good
stuff. Good stuff. All right. Gay cheating is like cheating but
worse. Well, it's it's gay cheating. You say gay cheating because
while it's not worse, it is
not something he ever claims publicly and he's married to a woman.
So, it's like a little interesting. Okay. It's a little interesting.
This video is going to >> reckless idiot. Apology to some
ordinary gamers and Nexo >> seem like a joke considering
it's the first thing I've uploaded since Mutar's response to
recent drama, but I assure you it is absolutely not. I'd like
to apologize unreservedly to Mutahar of some ordinary gamers
and Ryan of Nexo, as well as you, the viewer. This video has
not been prompted in any way by any third party. I just decided
this evening to check for information in a couple places I didn't.
And it turns out I screwed the pooch. I went full. I did exactly
what I would tear someone else apart for. I got a few pieces
that seemed like they fit together. And instead of continuing
to check and make sure, I boldly threw what I had out there and
even laughed at other people when this time I'm the joke. A link
to my previous video with corrections in the description can
be found below, but I'll summarize the problems here to try my
best to correct what I've done wrong. I shared a clip of Mutar
talking about making out with his friend Ryan at his friend Kyle's
wedding while he was in a I will also say this is super cool
that that uh Harmful Opinions has like this standard, right?
Yes, he has this standard where he holds people to his standard.
Okay, it's a very high standard, but he holds himself to that
standard, too. So, he [__] something up and he'll
come in and say, "Listen, I here's what I [__] up.
Here's how I [__] up. I'm an idiot. Okay, my bad."
It's like how you restore your actual credibility, right? You
go, "Here's how I [__] up. Here's here's why I [__]
up." And you know, there it's all on the table now. It's all
on the table, and if you want to keep watching me, you can. Right
now, this really isn't that big a [__] up. He like
kind of got he got a little too exuberant with with his the claims
he was making. Maybe you'd say if he did this on a stream, it
wouldn't be as bad. Maybe in an edited video he probably should
have checked, right? It's probably significantly worse in an
edited video, but it's good that he comes out and actually says,
"Hey, this this is where I screwed up, right?" Four 4 minutes
and 19 seconds for this little mixup as opposed to Mudahar's
30 seconds where he goes out and corrects what he did. Relationship
with a woman who was unhappy about that happening. I also shared
a clip of Mutahar talking to Ryan of Nexo about making out or
potentially sucking his dick because he is so blackout drunk
he won't remember it. Confirmation bias got the better of me.
I went, "Okay, light bulb. That's the Ryan." However, having
taken more time to look into it, which I should have before publishing
a video, I no longer think that's clear and think there may be
a different Ryan, who I found mentioned in older videos. Additionally,
I said I suspected Kyle's wedding where this gay cheating occurred
was a 2019 wedding that Mutahar had mentioned in a video. This
is absolutely not the case and Kyle's wedding occurred in 2017.
Further supporting the idea that the Ryan Mutah made out with
will have >> Dude, there's a I just want to say there's
going to be a big backlog of like massive YouTubers that people
are going to go do. There's so much money. There's so many views
and going back and and going through these big YouTubers and
seeing how they got big. It seems like to get big as a a as get
big as a streamer, get big as a YouTuber, a lot of these people
just lie about stuff. And now they've created very long-term
and permanent records of that lying. And there's just a ton of
money to be made and going back and checking through some of
the [__] they've said to figure out exactly where
they've misrepresented themselves. So Nicandros is doing that,
right? But I would expect a lot of other people to go and do
the same thing. to go to like big YouTubers who've been doing
this for a long time and and you just go and like you just check
all of their qualifications. You see what they've said about
it over time, see if it changes and build a narrative out of
that, right? People don't like frauds. It's amazing how many
uh how many people made it. People don't people think they don't
like frauds. People love frauds. Okay? Cuz the only people who
are confident like 100% confident so much of the time that they
build big audiences, they tend to be frauds, right? People don't
like indecision from streamers, from content creators. they don't
like it at all. And the people who are decisive are usually people
who don't know why they should be hesitant. Right? That's very
often what it is. It's very rare that you have somebody who is
hyperdecisive like like just they're they're making snap decisions
based on experience and knowledge.
It's usually somebody who's like kind of a grifter who can do
that. Right now, there are times where it's like, oh, you you
sort of you do that and then you can hold yourself accountable
and you can be entertaining and knowledgeable at the same time.
But I'd say those are far more rare. And it seems like, dude,
I can't believe Mudahar got away with it for so long cuz cuz
when he was telling me like when he's got one of the biggest
channels in his space on YouTube, he is like the king of an entire
vertical on YouTube. When he's telling me this isn't even my
full-time job, I'm like, dude, that sounds like complete and
utter bull, right? Like I I just look at that on its face. You're
one of the biggest channels on YouTube. You post videos every
day and you're like, this isn't even my full-time job. How how
the how the how the
could you even say that? Having a girlfriend may not have been
an expo unless Mutar knew him somehow before he started doing
YouTube, which I haven't seen to be the case. Additionally, I
showed a clip of Mutahar talking to Dr. K about a girlfriend
he'd had who was supposedly terminally ill, having end of life
care with serious heart conditions. I suggested this could have
been the girlfriend he had at the time of Car's wedding, but
now that I found that details of Car's wedding actually are online,
and it was in 2017, that must be incorrect. An absolute embarrassment.
I don't know what I was doing, not putting in the time I needed
to. And I again apologize unreservedly to Mutahar of some ordinary
gamers and Ryan of Nexo. I'm not sure how likely it is that either
of you will see this and I don't expect forgiveness given how
intentionally I went at and have been going at Mutahar, but I
am genuinely ashamed of my lack of due diligence in this instance.
Of course, actions speak louder than words to demonstrate my
remorse and my understanding of how badly I failed.
I What is he a dude? I like as well that he didn't take the video
down. He left it up as is with corrections here. Said, "Hey,
this is like updates, corrections, and description, right?" So,
he's not going to hide his shame. He's not going to hide his
up. He's He's going to address it head on. Take that and say,
"This is where I [__] up. Video stays up. >> This
is how it goes, guys. This this I'm going to be an example for
you. This mud, this is how you should handle your scandal. Uh,
Big Boats, thanks for the 12 months, buddy. Thank you. Thank
you. Thank you." >> The content like this is trash, worthless,
petty drama. And in response, I would say simply, "Yes, couple
years >> oh, sorry, sorry, sorry. Whoops. Whoops. That's
the old video." >> Here, not just with regard to the two
public figures I've wronged, but also my duty to you, the audience,
I will not be covering any further developments in this or anything
to do with some ordinary gamers beyond looking coverage on stream.
Because given my terrible performance in that previous video,
I don't think it's reasonable to expect anyone to trust me when
I publish original coverage. It's good to check things yourself
and you shouldn't trust blindly. But that's not the reality of
how people watch YouTube. Trust is a major factor. I've been
present. >> Oh man, I just become like every time I watch
this guy's videos, I just become like a bigger fan. I'm just
like, "Oh, this guy's awesome." Right? Like I think that's really
interesting that he's like, "Oh, I don't think people should
take me seriously here. I'm going to like stop covering this."
Like I I think that's difficult to do when you have a niche.
Like if you look at Sorry, this uh Where's the Let me open up
the gay video again. What did that get in the time that was up
before saying >> this got 84,000 views? Like this was a
massive video for him, right? He's not that big a channel. He
doesn't get views like he doesn't get crazy views. These have
been massive massive view videos for him, right? The Pirate Software
stuff was actually bigger. But still, I think other than Pirate
Software, this is his like second biggest guy he covers was the
Mudahar stuff. And now he's like, I'm not even going to cover
Mudahar anymore at all. Yeah. Yeah. I Dude, I just I love people
holding themselves accountable. presenting myself in a way that
I simply didn't live up to in that last video. And when someone
pretends to be something they're
>> what was the corrections? So, Flip Cork, I'm guessing
you just got here. So, the corrections were basically he messed
up the timeline. He kind of confused two people, some names.
He messed up timelines and he made some assertions that he felt
were
that he could make that he couldn't make and then he did more
research and he realized he was wrong. And so, he came out, he
published a video apologizing. He unlisted the previous video.
Okay. He unlisted his previous video entirely.
>> And yeah, he published a new video saying, "Here's here
are the I made. I apologize. I'm not going to even cover Mudahar
anymore because I I feel like I'm not responsible enough with
this." >> It would be ridiculous and wrong just to expect
everyone to overlook that. Should something worth talking about
come up in future. It will have to be after I believe I've earned
the right to expect your trust back. I will make no defense of
my mistakes. There is no defense. It was simply wrong not to
take the time I should have. I was aggressive, arrogant, and
negligent. I deserve all of the mockery I directed at Mutahar
in that last video and more. And while I stand behind the videos
before the last one, they cannot be weighed against these mistakes.
You cannot say, "Sorry, I did something wrong." But look at all
this good I did. Good behavior doesn't buy you the right to do
some >> oncreen chat. Yeah, dude. The social stream stuff
seems to be having some real issues. I don't know. I don't know
why it's like having issues like this. >> Something wrong
now. And there >> I might I don't know if maybe maybe I
should run all of Social Stream in a different uh browser than
my than Chrome. Like maybe I need to run it in Firefox or something.
I'll I'll test it out tomorrow. You refresh cash on this. This
should get it working. >> If anything, it only makes it
worse cuz it means there's a bunch of stuff that's worthwhile
that your mistake undermines people's ability to trust and want
to engage with. I present myself as competent and having an eye
for detail. I talk as if I'm better than those I'm covering.
But in that last video, that was absolutely not the case. It
might come across as weird that I'm saying so much and I'm not
trying to self flagagillate or something. But if I don't make
it clear that I know everything I have to be sorry for, why on
earth would you believe I'm sorry at all. Not to say it's merely
about convincing you. In fact, I'm sure many of you do not care
either way. You just like a video that'll give you a laugh. But
it's not about you feeling offended or feeling wronged. It's
about what I did being wrong. I am sorry for what I did wrong
and once again I apologize unreservedly to Mutar of some ordinary
gamers and Ryan of Nexo. So Jay Pine cone asks is he being too
dramatic? I get it. He screwed up but self flagagillating but
he's self flagagillating a bit. Uh okay, you could say that but
he holds himself to the standard because he holds everybody else
to this exact standard, right? Like this is a this is a standard
he wants to hold everybody else to and and he has to apply it
to himself. He has very strict standards for what he expects
out of people who are doing coverage, especially even drama coverage,
right? Like he came out of the Gamergate stuff. So his his base
like understanding of the internet and how he handles drama is
if you are lying to people, if you're lying to people, if you're
misrepresenting yourself, if you are doing something shady behind
the scenes, that has to be called out. And when you make mistakes,
it's important to actually allow criticism of those mistakes.
If you don't allow criticism, if you don't take criticism well,
then everything gets up. That's like his belief as as far as
I know. That's that's like how he believes in in doing coverage.
So, I just appreciate it. I appreciate that he, you know, is
willing to to hold himself to the same standard he holds everybody
else to. Yeah. Okay. From here, we will go take a look. Mudahar
posted a new video yesterday and in this video, he actually goes
through and makes a comment about the engineering stuff. Okay,
he's going to go he's going to make his comment. We'll evaluate.
I like that we watched the harmful opinions video first because
now we can compare how Mudahar holds himself to account holds
himself accountable to how Harmful held himself accountable.
Okay, so spoiler alert Muda doesn't do a great job. The age estimation
coming at least in the United States and I can only imagine this
will hit the entire world. Now YouTube's pretty much engineered
I would say in their mind it seems a pretty foolproof way of
isolating kitties from adults. Now I use the eword over there
and I want to just start talking a little bit. I know there's
been some drama. Now, I used the eword over there and I >> the
eword the engineer word. >> Let me just start talking a
little bit. I know there's been some drama and I want to kind
of address things here really quickly. So, obviously uh I have
uh been calling myself a engineer in some cases, a programmer,
a cyber security engineer, whatever you can call it. And uh you
know, I apparently have also been a dropout which I don't hide.
Now, obviously, >> what? Okay, I just pay attention to
the language, right? Right. I apparently have been. You lived
your life. You lived your own experience. Why the are you saying
I apparently have been I maybe might have could have been. What
are you talking about, bro? What are you talking about? How does
that make any sense at all? Hold on. I need to fix this chat.
I just realized I had it way too big. Apparently, I might have
also been a drop. Yeah, apparently. Bro, it's you. You That's
you. What do you mean? Apparently you're the biggest expert on
you and your lived experience. >> Me being obviously uh
I have uh been calling myself a engineer in some cases a programmer
a cyber security engineer whatever you can call it and uh >> you
did not wait did I >> talking a little bit I know there's
been
>> and I want to kind of address things here really quickly
>> want to address it. >> So obviously uh I have
uh been calling myself a engineer in some cases a programmer
a cyber security engineer whatever you can call it. So he's been
calling himself programmer, engineer, cyber security expert.
Okay. He also said computer engineer >> and uh you know
I apparently have >> I apparently been a dropout which
I >> I apparently have also been a dropout which I don't
hide. Okay. So there's still no he hasn't taken responsibility
for misrepresenting himself at all. >> Now obviously me
being a dropout I don't have a degree so I'm not a certified
or licensed engineer. Now, I made a lot of videos in the past
where I've taught you guys about computer safety, cyber security,
a lot of this stuff, and I think that content stands up on its
own, and I believe it actually can be used, you know, and people
have learned from it, and I think that's great. >> Now,
if you feel offended, if you feel wronged that I called myself
an engineer while not being a degreeholding engineer, then for
that, I I do >> No, I I'm offended that you represented
yourself as such very intentionally.
I I would say I'm most offended by the idea that I'm just like
my feelings are hurt because of the misrepresentation, right?
Like
this is like somebody coming out imagine. Okay.
Mark Magguire, Sammy Sosa, who who holds the home run record
now in the in the MLB. I can't remember. Probably still Mark
Magguire, right? I don't I don't know. But there there was like
when when steroids first entered baseball, a bunch of people
took steroids, right? Oh, it's Barry Bonds. Great. It's Barry
Bonds. So, uh, so a bunch of people took steroids. You get caught
taking steroids. You don't go, "Well, apparently some people,
despite me being, you know, double the size of like 3 years ago,
some people thought I was playing clean." And if you thought
I was playing clean, I apologize. But, you know, I think my home
runs stand on their own. It's it's like it's not quite analogous
one to one, but it's like you did something wrong. You put yourself
ahead of other people. You put yourself above other people, and
you use this qualification to go after other people, right? You've
gone after people for misrepres misrepresenting themselves. You've
gone after people for I misrepresenting qualifications. I don't
know if that's precisely what you've done, but you know what
you've done wrong. And here you're pretending that like, oh,
well, if like a little misspeak on my part offends you, like,
I'm sorry. I made it clear I was a dropout. No, you didn't. No,
you didn't. And that's been proven out in all these videos that
you did not make it clear. You actually very, very intentionally
offiscated it. And now you're trying to treat everybody like
they're [__] This should actually upset people as
much as like everything else that's been revealed that his way
of taking accountability is saying like apparently I also called
myself a dropout and apparently you know I'm a I have a like
a problem over here. I dude just come out and say yeah I I said
it that way and I use that qualification and I was wrong to do
that. Just say you were wrong. Barry Bonds would have been a
Hall of Famer even without the steroids. Wait, is he not a Hall
of Famer? No, he definitely got he definitely got in the Hall
of Fame, right? He was a really good player. You know, Jtock
is white when he is naming McGuire before Bonds. I just uh when
I was in like kindergarten, grade 1, grade two, like a long long
long time ago, okay, long long long time ago, I think it's like
kindergart. I my my family watched Sports Center in the morning,
okay, before I went to school. And I just remember watching Sammy
Sosa hit a dinger, okay? He'd hit a dinger and then he do his
little like hop along. And I thought that was the coolest thing.
I like baseball when I was really young. So Sammy Sosa, Mark
Magcguire, that whole thing, right? Bonds came after. I remember
Bonds came after, but I I Yeah, I lost it. I didn't watch as
much once I Yeah, once I could actually control the TV remote.
Anyway, so Munahar is not really doing his admission of guil.
Yeah, his he's not admitting what he did wrong, right? He's going,
"Well, I kind of I put all the information out there and you
know, you came to the wrong conclusion. You could have come to
you could have come to the correct conclusion if you cared, but
you came to the wrong conclusion." It's like, "No, you said 99
times you're an engineer. You said one time you're a dropout."
That does not let people come to the correct conclusion. That
is not accurately representing yourself. And that's the problem.
That's the criticism. And he won't even he won't even take it
on the chin like a good >> And uh I will denigrate myself
to, you know, I guess programmer or a fat Indian guy that knows
a bit about computers. That's what I'll leave it at. >> Dude,
well, just say just say you misrepresented yourself. >> And
uh that's pretty much all I have to say. Now again, if you want
to stick around, awesome. If you still feel wronged and this
does not suffice for you, then um I don't really give a simple
as that. Now, uh again, that being said, if anything else comes,
this is probably the best way to address this for the sake of
his channel. I will say he's probably addressing it in the best
professional way for himself, right? Assuming he doesn't have
a bunch of other stuff, assuming the Candros doesn't have a whole
bunch of other here, right? But it's pretty clear to everybody
who actually followed this, who watched the videos that yeah,
you massively misrepresented yourself to everybody, Mudahar,
like massively. And you refuse to come out and actually admit
it. I assume this is the best way he can respond for his channel,
but also it's just it's like the reason I guess you should look
at a lot of big YouTubers like this with some skepticism. Some
just an appropriate level of skepticism. Why do he Why does he
wear his hair in that weird ugly comb over? It's so bad. Uh,
I just assume he basically never does his hair. Why point it
out in the first place? Because if you don't point it out, people
will keep going and spamming engineer engineer engineer in all
your chats. If you never address it at all, that probably blows
up into something else. Right? But if you address it, now he
can say, "Well, I did address it. Go watch the video. I addressed
it. I clearly addressed it." Right? So, you don't give people
the ability to say, "You just ran and hid all the criticism and
you never addressed it at all." Now, he says, "I addressed it."
And it's like a totally fake addressing of the problem. Right?
It's not real. too busy scratching his balls to comb his hair.
Dude, I I appreciate that he makes a video a day. Like, that
does take quite a bit of work, right? No time to do your hair
when you make a video a day out of this, you know, uh whether
there will be some legal stuff done. I'll just let lawyers handle
it and we'll call it at that. But that being said, I want to
move forward and uh that's pretty much the engineered response
that I had to give. That being said, let's look even further
into dude.
>> Okay. Okay. Well,
>> that's that's his response. That is what it is.
>> Cam, thank you for the 15 months, the announcement.
Let's go. Thank you. Thank
>> Yeah, if you guys are just rolling in, we're starting
with the Mudahar content. We haven't even really gotten this
is uh we haven't even really gotten to the primary piece of content
for today, which will be the new Neandros Mudahar video. All
right, we're going to do that and then after that, we'll get
into the pro probably the Zena MK stuff, I think. JT, are you
an engineer? No. I've had the title of software engineer before.
Um, but I am not an engineer. Uh, there's there's like an engineering
college in most universities where you get an engineering degree
that is explicit in Canada and you get this iron ring, right?
And I have a lot of friends who got that iron ring and they get
super mad about anybody calling themselves an engineer, right?
There's this whole story about how in Canada, I believe it's
in Canada, how like a bridge collapse because of shoddy engineering
and they do like this this iron ring to to like kind of pay homage
to that bridge and say like actually engineering needs to be
taken seriously. Actually, there needs to be standards here.
You cannot just have you cannot just use this title willy-nilly.
Like we actually have to hold ourselves accountable. The iron
ring, I think, symbolizes holding holding themselves accountable.
I I said this before. I think somebody might have corrected me.
What's the difference? um you go to it's just like a harder it's
a more challenging curriculum in most universities in Canada
like in engineering you you take different courses almost all
of your courses that you take like the standard ones you have
to take the harder version so for calculus you have to take a
harder version of calculus for stats you have to take a harder
version of stats and then all the engineering classes are tremendously
hard I think they might even possibly be like a higher um like
all the classes are harder and there's a lot more work uh at
least at my university it was famous that Like yeah the engineering
program was way harder. You probably had like double the work
of most other programs in undergrad. Yeah. Yeah. On the other
B in the US and level one help desk people calling themselves
customer engineers. Yeah. They call themselves engineers. I don't
know what the deal is with that. It is weird. J called themselves
a psychometrician. A psycho magician. Dude, it is funny how how
much this overlaps the Sunday stuff. It's just like a little
amusing. Yeah,
a little amusing. Okay, we're done with the Mudahar stuff or
we're done with Mudahar and harmful. Apparently, we're done with
harmful content on Mudahar. But breaking news about 20 minutes,
I think before the stream started.
>> Nandros,
our favorite Finnish YouTuber. Okay. Put out another video. This
wasn't Mudahar's first time. This wasn't Mudahar's first time.
Mudahar has responded to the engineer criticisms. While I didn't
expect my video to blow up like this, the circus has proven quite
convenient as it had provided yet another clear-cut example of
Mutahar trying his best to avoid accountability and hide things
from his audience. Except this time, people can see it clearly.
But he's behaved like this before regarding way more serious
issues. And I think it's time to start talking about them because
there's more to this story than someone lying about their job.
Oh sh was that another theme in his primary video? Could you
imagine? Is Nicandros just like actually Yagami Light? Is that
who is that who Nicandros is? Is he sitting here like actually
putting out new videos? He's like engineered this precisely.
So he drops the the title video and waits for Mudahar to like
totally dodge accountability and then he drops the accountability
video and then he he then he's waiting. Mudahar is going to come
out and play the victim. Okay. He's going to play the victim
to everybody. He's going to go guys in anti-India racism. Look
at all these thumbnails. Anti-indra racism is unacceptable. And
I'm getting off social media a while cuz for a while cuz drama's
crazy. So, he does that and then Nandros drops the like, oh,
Mutahar plays the race uh the race card video. Okay, maybe he's
just got like 10 videos waiting go waiting to go ready loaded
into the chamber and he's just going to keep dropping them as
Mudahar displays the exact behaviors that we can all we've all
come to expect. Maybe that's what's happening. Nandro is just
writing in his death note. Exactly. >> I'm Nikandros. You
may have seen my previous video. Mutahar's been a fake engineer
for 10 years. The video's been way more successful than I ever
expected. I assumed it would simmer in the background for a month
before I released my big video, but it blew up instantly and
Mutahar has responded. In the video, I exposed Mutahar for giving
inconsistent statements about his educational background and
qualifications. Did he go to university for computer engineering
or computer science? Did he drop out after a semester or does
he leave it open to leave his audience to conclude he graduated?
Sometimes he'll talk about STEM degrees while claiming to be
an engineer and therefore biased in favor of them despite the
fact that he has no such degree. >> Is it bad if you don't
get a STEM degree? Look, I'm going to sound biased as [__]
but uh STEM degrees all the way. I'm going sound biased cuz you
know as an engineer like you know you want to get the degree
that's going to get you a job, you know, a good a good job.
>> Why would you be biased when you don't have what? >> Not
saying other degrees can't, but like You got to be smart. >> If
he wasn't trying to be deceptive, why didn't he say, "I don't
have a degree, but I'm still an engineer." By the way, it does
seem to be the case that merely holding yourself out to the public
as an engineer is a violation of the law in Ontario where Mutahar
lives. As professional engineers Ontario, a self-regulatory body,
not a random engineer labor union has fined a politician in 2016
for introducing himself as an >> Majid Jawari >> engineer
on television when he wasn't a licensed engineer. Do note that
this person used to be a fully licensed engineer, degreeholding
professional engineer, but because he was no longer licensed,
he lost the right to call himself an engineer. There is no jail
time for breaking this law, only a fine if he refused to cease
misusing this protected title. Despite admitting at points that
he was a former engineer, that he was a dropout, Mutah was introducing
himself as an engineer as recently as June of 2025. I feel like
I feel like a doctor trying to explain like how medical procedures
work as an engineer telling people that AI like >> and
at time >> uh you do not get a ring for this. You do not
get an iron ring. Um be very vivic. It's it's like a Canadian
engineer thing. The iron rings >> he leaned on these credentials
to sound more authoritative. I also constructed a timeline which
demonstrated that Mutahar has been a former engineer for a decade.
He was getting a videography diploma. He worked as a video editor,
but in 2019, he began calling himself not just an engineer, but
a computer engineer. Note that he has never called himself a
software engineer. A computer engineer isn't some Canadian English
version of a
>> Yes, computer engineer is somebody who does like uh
what would you call it? Like not CAD. Oh, what are these called?
A verilog. Verilog diagrams. Like they build like processor infrastructure.
They they design components. They they're a different kind. They're
a specific they are specifically an engineer. They're like um
they're way more tangentially related to I think electrical engineers
than they are to computer science degrees, right? You could probably
have a computer there's a lot of overlap. I definitely took classes
with a lot of compen compen students like computer engineering
students but it's um yeah it's it's like it is an engineering
degree. It is an engineering degree. You do a lot of the engineering
stuff way >> engineer. It's a much more hardware development
focused engineering discipline closer to electrical engineering.
Mutahar does not display this kind of knowledge or skill in his
content. It took him months to switch the batteries on his smoke
detector. He's been calling himself a computer engineer for a
decade because of computer work he did in high school. He claims
to have done penetration testing, that he's a cyber security
expert, that he does network security, and that he was coding
bank applications. As a high schooler, he claimed he would have
made a lot of money in these fields, but also that it was a dead-end
job. Is there any proof that these jobs were ever real? Is there
proof that his globe trottting video engineer career was real?
I don't know. According to further research by harmful opinions,
Mutahar called his work blue collar computer programming before
he switched to calling it engineering in 2015. And that term
stuck with him for 10 years misleading millions of people into
perceiving him as far more qualified and educated than he was
others. >> So that is the problem is like he would be in
this in this vertical in this space right and he'd be somebody
who's like talking about you know some niche programming thing
and he would represent himself as an engineer. That is a way
you can get people to stay on to not drop off of your video right
is say I'm an expert in this field. I'm an expert and you should
listen to me because I have a valid opinion here. and and claiming
that without the actual expertise, without the actual qualifications
is just wrong to do. Like it's objectively wrong to do. No matter
how much he goes, well guys, if you feel like I misled you, then
I don't give a right. If you're like, sorry, then sorry, don't
watch me. But if you if you want to keep watching me and complaining
about it, I don't give a [__] Shut up. Get out of
here. Right? It's like, dude, you did something wrong. Just just
take responsibility. ers have pointed out that he used his credibility
to smear Mama Max as having possessed child abuse material, beastiality,
or animal abuse
>> The video that you would have would have to be hashed
by the FBI or any of these agencies is actual child and it would
>> No, it wouldn't. I don't know where he signed this.
He literally just read a Reddit post. >> There was no
>> wait the video that you have >> reality or animal
>> Hold on. Let's Let's see this. Uh, the mega is taken
down. What exactly did they say? Who exactly did who say or what
exactly did who say? The mega staff when they investigated it.
I was not in charge of the drives. If someone on my team, uh,
it was someone on my team who would distribute something
the blah blah blah. Uh, if you have any more questions, >> abuse
videos
that you would have would have to be hashed by the FBI or any
of these agencies is actual child and it >> No, it wouldn't.
I don't know. Okay. Okay, I keep getting messages about the the
lack of a notification for kick. Guys, the solution to this is
going to the blastoff tweet which is pinned in the kick chat
or the Twitch chat. Okay, we got the blastoff tweet pinned in
both locations. Go like the blastoff tweet. Go retweet the blastoff
tweet. Engage with the blastoff tweet. Okay, so most more people
know that the stream is on that we're going we're going hard
right now with the stream, guys. Okay. Oh, whoops. I should repost
this on my timeline. Uh like this part two, guys. Okay. Let everybody
know the stream is going. We're here. Dickers jump scare. Wait,
hold on. Everybody says this dickers jump scare. Why don't you
guys like dickers? I like dickers. What do you Why do you guys
hate dickers? Yeah, I know you guys didn't get notifications
from kick. I know it was broken today. I'm sorry for that. Okay,
all you need to do is be in the Discord. I'll always make sure
there's a Discord notification for you. Okay, who the [__]
is Dickers? This is Dickers. I love Dickers. Dicker's cool. Dickers
a good guy. Where he signed this? He literally just read a Reddit
post. >> So hashing a video. So basically what would happen
is the FBI probably has like hashed child stuff to make sure
that they can check a video without anybody having to watch it,
right? Is this a video already in our library of videos? If it
is, then we could just confirm right away that is like child
you need to need to we we'll take these appropriate steps, right?
That's like I can see but telling somebody who's reporting child
for the first time like especially something that would be bespoke
like they they know somebody who's the victim of
uh being recorded for CESAM stuff, right? Like that that wouldn't
be something the FBI would have. They wouldn't hash that. You
can't like hash a video to find out if it's child or not. That's
not how that works. >> There was no proof of this. The
only reason he was believed was because he was perceived to have
these high credentials. Mutahar's initial response to my video
was to ban the word engineer from his comments. When that didn't
succeed, he stopped uploading for a week and went quiet on social
media. >> So, at this point, you know, we're about like
a week into not crapping, right? >> He did private a video
which harmful opinions cover in one of his videos, and he wiped
an entire channel of podcast he used to do with his friends,
meaning that he was following this quite closely behind the scenes.
Now he's back and he's made a twominute response buried 3 minutes
into a random 32minute video. Let's see it >> now. YouTube's
>> Oh, that is another point, one I didn't make that. Hey,
he's going to say he responded,
but that response is buried fairly deep into a video. So, it
is difficult to know exactly what his response is. >> Pretty
much engineered. I would say in their mind, it seems a pretty
foolproof way of isolating kitties from adults. Now, I use the
eword over there and I want to just start talking a little bit.
I know there's been some drama and I want to kind of address
things here really quickly. So, obviously uh I have uh been calling
myself a engineer in some cases, a programmer, a cyber security
engineer, whatever you can call it. And uh you know, I apparently
have also been a dropout which I don't hide. Now, obviously that
kills me. The apparently I hope Nicandros just lights him up
for the apparently. Right. What do you mean apparently, bro?
What the [__] do you mean?
That's your life. And apparently I killed a person in 1996. Apparently
I I you know, I've heard this. So some people have said this.
Apparently I killed somebody in 1996. You you never know it from
meeting me. I'm a pretty nice guy, but you know, it >> Me
being a dropout, I don't have a degree. So I'm not a certified
or licensed engineer. Now, I made a lot of videos in the past
where I've taught you guys about computer safety, cyber security,
a lot of this stuff. And I think that content stands up on its
own and I believe it actually can be used, you know, and people
have learned from it and I think that's great. Oh, before we
get through this guys, I'm going to end on Twitch and go over
to kickonly. So, head on over to kick. We're on kick only. Hop
over there. Get on the get onto the kick stream, okay?
We're going to go kick only for the rest of the stream. I love
you guys. But we have to go kick only cuz we're going to end
up doing the xenomk stuff and I don't even know if I can show
like people fighting on on Twitch. It might just get me banned.
So, love you guys. Head on over to kick. We'll see you there
shortly. Okay. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Give them a second
to switch over. This is what I was thinking of. Yeah, this is
what I was thinking of. Brazilian lad. This this old meme. This
old meme, you know. Yes. Now, if you feel offended, if you feel
wronged that I called myself an engineer while not being a degreeholding
engineer, then for that I I do apologize and uh I will denigrate
myself to, you know, I guess programmer or a fat Indian guy that
knows a bit about computers. That's what I'll leave it at. And
uh that's pretty much all I have to say. Now again, if you want
to stick around, awesome. If you still feel wronged and this
does not suffice for you, then um I don't really give a simple
as that. Now, uh again, that being said, if anything else comes
out of this, you know, uh whether there will be some legal stuff,
then I'll just let lawyers handle it and we'll call it that.
But that being said, I want to move forward and uh that's pretty
much the engineered. So big so big of mudahar. Okay guys, if
there guys, if I get sued for misrepresenting myself, I'll just
let my lawyers h handle it, okay? It won't mean anything. I I
just listen. It won't mean anything. I'll just deliver that.
>> I ended my video in a pretty melodramatic phrase. The
only power I have is the one you give me when you lie. That was
my awkward cringy attempt at conveying to Mutahar in a brief
and concise manner that as long as he keeps lying, all he does
is hurt himself. He had the choice of telling the truth. But
once again, he's misled his audience. >> Dude, Nandra is
sitting over here like Jigsaw. Okay.
Huh? Let's play a Let's play a game, Mudahar. Let's play a game.
You have two choices. You can take accountability for your for
your screw-ups, okay? You can take accountability for your misrepresentations
of yourself, or I can continue I can continue cutting pieces
of flesh off of you one at a time,
an ounce at a time until there's nothing left of you. Just he's
like psych. He is kind of like a psychopath. It's very fun to
watch. Okay. Very fun to watch >> about what happened.
He is betting on them, not knowing anything about the >> live
or die, the choice is yours >> situation. And he's omitting
massive amounts of context in an effort to mislead them. He's
been, among other things, misappropriating a protected title
for a decade to come across as more authoritative to his audience.
He's been lying to them for 10 years. Now, if you feel offended,
if you feel wronged, >> every little thing from the visuals
to the word choices is him dodging accountability and attempting
to downplay it. Hey, look, I'm in on the joke.
Look at these videos where I'm looking at code and computer code
looking things. I must be pretty advanced. Um, apparently I'm
a dropout without any higher education that an engineer would
have. I don't know why that's relevant. He claims he doesn't
hide it, but this has called himself an engineer like 70 times
while he's revealed himself to be a dropout like five times.
Your audience doesn't see all of your content. If Mutah believed
that was true, he would be smart enough not to lie like this
in the first place. >> Now, I made a lot of videos,
Nandros knows. Okay, I'm so happy that I'm watching Nandros make
the criticisms. Okay, the criticisms seem obvious and and there
he is repeating them one to one. Let's go. Yeah, you can't you
can't do a hundred wrong things and then you can't lie a 100
times and then correct it once hidden within those 100 lies and
then have everybody understand exactly what's going on. That
that's not how anything >> In the past where I've taught
you guys about computer safety, cyber security, a lot of this
stuff and I think that content stands up on its own and I believe
it actually can be used, you know, and people have learned from
it and I think that's great. Claiming that people have learned
from his content is an incredibly low bar and not something that
was contested in the first place. If you like to use the brush
tools in Photoshop, did you know that by holding down Alt and
right click, you can move your mouse to change the size and the
hardness of your brush. Congratulations, thousands of Photoshop
users. >> No way, dude. Oh, why does dude somehow Indians
are just like free game for racism on the internet every single
time >> watching this video just rush to open the software
in order to try that trick. People have learned from this video.
But I don't need to call myself a graphic design engineer or
someone working in TV and film to woe an audience. If I made
content that I believed stood up on its own, I wouldn't have
to inflate my credentials. So, this is a nonsense >> Me
being a dropup, I don't have a degree. So, I'm not a uh certified
or licensed engineer. >> His phrasing here implies he is
still an engineer, just not a degreeholding engineer. What engineer
are you then? After 10 years of bragging about it in public,
making it our business. You should be able to tell us where did
this come from, what are your credentials, what work have you
done? You believe in open-source software. You call yourself
a programmer. Where's your GitHub? What contributions have you
made in the past 10 years? Then he tries to guilt trip people
by saying he'll denigrate himself by calling himself just a programmer
or a fat Indian who knows a bit about computers. He could have
said that he was insecure in his youth and used the word engineer
without knowing it was illegal to feel better about himself.
Then that claim kind of stuck around and he was too embarrassed
to admit that he wasn't one. It would be so simple, but Mutahar
cannot ever admit to having made a mistake or at least >> Yes.
This is the This is Oh man. Exactly.
Exactly right. This is the not so I I I you know refer to as
the not so erodite whistleblower conundrum, okay? That you think
that admitting you're wrong on the internet means that you just
like have to off forever or you lose all of your audience. That's
not the case, dude. People make mistakes and it's this idea that
you can't make mistakes or that you have to be perfect, right?
And holding other people to that exact level or that exact bar,
that's what gets people into trouble. Just don't hold people
to like perfection and you're fine, man. Cuz Yeah, exactly. Hey,
I was just I was like I was just insecure would have been a perfect
response. I said I I was insecure cuz I didn't have the qualifications
and people kind of doubted my stuff just off it just on its face
and I misrepresented myself. Yeah. Boom. You're you're so golden
with that response. >> Just take responsibility for it.
What do you think makes you come across as a likable man of character?
someone with the footing to judge others as you have done for
years. >> I'm kind of the afficionado of handing out these
>> Oh, this is interesting. Top Bronson. Yes, I could see
this being a huge source of like like it is just being a YouTuber
is like filtered down. You end up getting into YouTube because
you can do it. You you don't really work in normal jobs that
well. So, a lot of these YouTubers get into working for themselves
because they just can't admit their mistakes. And that's key
to teamwork. Yeah, it really is being able to admit your mistakes
and not not like get totally mind by them, not get totally like
run down by them and to like call out other people's mistakes
without totally destroying them too. These are key facets of
teamwork and I think a lot of YouTubers kind of suck at this
totally just totally suck at it. They can't do it. >> Reality
checks to a lot of things. >> Is it by being a coward who
lies all the time, shifts blame, and never accepts their fallibility?
Or is it by being someone who takes the blame for their mistakes?
Someone who knows their limits and speaks the truth. Do you believe
your audience is entitled to the truth about who you are because
they will only trust you as much as you trust them. They will
respect you as much as you respect them. Now they've realized
you're full of [__] >> I was full of literally
like I was full of feal matter. >> And what's your response?
>> If you still feel wronged and this does not suffice
for you, then um I don't really give a simple as that. This behavior
is not really to your benefit at all. It benefits your critics,
but it especially benefits me. Now, a large chunk of your audience
and the public knows you're full of and it's not that hard anymore
to convince them that you've done this exact thing before. Dear
viewer, did you feel confused when Mutahar came out with his
video denouncing Naku? Did you feel he was overreacting? that
he was distancing himself from him pretty hardcore relative to
his actual points of discontent. Well, that's just like what
happened here. Mutah omitted massive amounts of context because
if he told you the full truth, he would have to admit that while
he was eager to attack and condemn creators like Eva Chris Tyson,
for being fans of a lollyorn artist, or for having kids on a
Discord server with >> the Knucks conundrum, too. Dude,
I think this is uh this is sort of where
whole criticism of Mudahar comes from is like how he handled
a lot of his relations with KN. And yes, Mudahar does this all
of the time. This is why harmful opinions had to go hard on himself,
right, for up that video. You have to hold yourself to the standard
that you hold everybody else to. If you can't hold yourself to
the standard you hold everybody else to, then you have up and
it will it will destroy you eventually. Maybe not before you
make with Mudahar. I think Mudahar is getting out of this sitting
pretty, right? Mudar is almost certainly set for life. There's
just no reason to believe he's not set for life right now, right?
So, he's kind of getting out of it, but but it will destroy you
eventually.
>> He was running cover for and defending someone who turned
that into their entire content model. >> Forgive me, Lord,
but I did it. Please forgive me. Stop sending Gentai. Why? I
already lost. No, not November. Half of my class saw Aquad's
butthole on my screen. To be fair, mad respect for sending Aqua's
butthole and your class should be thankful. >> That's a
post from Knoxaku's subreddit. At the time this video was made,
the OP of this post was a 12year-old child. They were
me. That's that is brutal. Wait, is that that's not a meme? I
feel like have they checked that to see if that's a meme? I wonder
if there's anything that validates that beyond just the words
specifically. But yeah, this is the entire criticism behind Nucks,
right? You create a persona that's appealing to children and
then you talk about that's like children. That is an obvious
recipe for disaster. An obvious one that Mudahar can call out
in the Chris Tyson situation, but he cannot call out when it
comes to his friend, his friend Nuxtaku. He will just let that
go. >> Not a one-time poster. And they were not the only
extremely young child that was involved in this community focused
around adult content. There's plenty more material to cover in
my >> Oh, wait. Focused around adult content. >> The
12-year-old child sharing the source image of the hentai. Oh.
Oh, no.
Oh, no. >> There's plenty more material to cover in my
bigger video, but let me tell you this. Mutahar was notified
about this stuff in a confrontation almost exactly a year ago.
What action did he take? Nothing. Because if the truth came out,
he would look bad for being so close to Naktaku. This guy is
sitting here. >> Hold on. Did nothing happen or did he
like weirdly disavowed KN in like a He like disavowed Knucks
and then took it back,
right? It wasn't that he necessarily did nothing. He like made
sure you all knew that he was aware of it, that he had he had
seen it, and then he took it back for no reason. Like no clear
reason whatsoever. So I wouldn't even say he did nothing. He
he did something. He he basically himself by proving that he
knew about it and then he locked it back entirely. They're telling
you that the government needs to stay away from the internet.
It's so horrible when people are forced to verify their age on
social media. I know it's annoying. I know it's frustrating.
And I know it can be used for information control, mass manipulation,
censorship, blah blah blah. But I've seen what it looks like
when these manchildren self-regulate. What it looks like when
they are holding each other accountable. And what I mean by that
is that they don't. They are 100% willing to prioritize their
career, income, and their ego over the safety of children on
the platform. But that's a story for the bigger video. Some people
have unfortunately gotten the idea that I'm going to expose Mutahar
as some kind of a that is not the case. He's not refusing to
call this stuff out because he secretly condones it. He is simply
just that much of a total afraid of any controversy with a chance
it might stain his reputation. A worthless, spineless pushover.
Somehow his actions in this situation were even more pathetic
than pretending to be different kinds of engineer for a decade.
>> That's not surprising that Nickandress feels that way.
I think there was a lot of lying and a lot of scummy scummy that
he did. There's that there's the uh yeah, it's the Mama Maxu
and now this situation all exhibit the same pattern of behavior
for Mudahar, right? It is the same pattern of behavior. Minimizing
what he did wrong, refusing to acknowledge stuff. Oh, I'm going
to actually walk away for a while, guys. I'm going to actually
walk away. Okay, I'm going to go over here. I'm going to pretend
I don't know about any of this for a little bit, right? Mudahar
begs for the wall. Why would you why would you make this? Thank
you. But why? But why? But why?
It's It's the So the Mama Max thing, he basically didn't do his
due diligence. He totally he totally boosted this guy. And then
when Mama Max was kind of getting taken down, he refused to actually
come out and say what he did wrong. Then you go to the Nikandros
or sorry, the Noxaku situation where he is presented, there's
videos made by Nikandros, right? showing exactly what was wrong
with that situation. What ex exactly what went wrong, right?
So Nikandra posted this video the sorry the mud mudahar n right
explaining what was wrong with Nux why Mudahar was wrong for
continuing to platform him and then Mudahar did his disavowel
and then after the disavow he went back on it it's it's tragic
the Naku shad link not just that be very vivic it's not just
the shad link right it's not just the shad link it's uh what
else is it is the shadlink it is noaku using actual lolly like
hentai censored for his thumbail es as well and getting people
to look at Lolly Hentai on streams or on pieces of content with
him, right? And getting them to react. It is like all of the
things that he wanted to criticize Chris Tyson for are all things
NX has done. Nux built a brand on it really.
And Mudahar's friends with him and then he wants to criticize
uh Chris Tyson as well. It's it's smacks of hypocrisy really
badly. Yeah. So, it's just a it's a pattern of behavior over
time where he is just not he's not able to be held accountable
for anything
and it's starting to starting to blow up in his face a lot. 16,000
views on this bad boy already. Let's go like the video. Let me
throw this in chat for you guys.
Go like the video, guys. Like the video. Watch the video. Like
the video. Watch the video. Okay, I think that's it for the Mudahar
stuff today.